[Applaudissements]
je crois big bisou avant 20 heures une
personne du même sexe mais de lui faire
de vous faire un bisou d'accord salim
on va jouer pour un très beau cadeau
salim pour l'instant qui bien sûr parce
qu'il est très fort et se passerait bien
attention c'est parti
c'est parti c'est parti oh non attention
nous ayons salim pour l'instant s'anime
à gagner de cadeaux s'anime à gagner
notre shopping plus la tablette tactile
vous allez jouer maintenant pour une
caméra ou le bisou c'est là bas on leur
amène ici avant chez moi je vais ramener
la place al-assi ou alors les pierres de
vie auprès d'accor bravo bravo savent
professionnel a tout de suite les
parties au niveau du même sexe à trois
garçons sont partis il ya beaucoup
prendre que trois ans vient de sauver
même surpris les chouettes même sauvé
vienne sauver francs j'invite la vitre
empêche toi c'est donc ton retour à ses
premières démos
il a tourné la tête je n'ai pas pu le
montrer le cheminement des piétons le
patron merci beaucoup
c'est pas mal aux pattes arrières salles
[Applaudissements]
merci merci merci merci mon chéri
d'amour merci animal et tu peux
retourner le public bad